global food prices rising at an alarming
rate worsening inflation and making it
difficult for families around the world
what will it mean for vulnerable
communities and how long will the trend
continue this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show i'm sami
zaydan food and energy prices are at
historic highs around the globe and
inflation is expected to rise in the
coming months the united nations food
agency is warning the higher costs of
putting people at risk especially those
living in developing countries
while in rich nations it's sparking
anger in seeing politicians scramble for
a solution in the united states
inflation hit its highest levels in 40
years in the united kingdom hundreds of
people marched this week protesting
against rising inflation tax increases
and higher energy bills
and in eastern europe latin america and
the pacific people have also been
finding the high cost of food to be too
much
let's take a look at some of the biggest
price hikes in recent months then in
south africa basic food items are more
expensive than they were a year ago 6.3
percent higher according to statistics
the same trend goes for new zealand
where food prices increased by 4.5
percent in december the highest in 10
years
in india the retail inflation rate rose
to a six-month high of 5.59
in december largely fueled by the
pandemic
in canada food and energy prices are
also going up rising by 5.7 for grocery
items compared to last year
and in the u.s egg and meat prices are
some of the most expensive at 7.4
percent higher than they were a year ago
well let's bring in our guests to the
show we have joining us from newcastle
in the uk jas calra assistant professor
in supply chain management at newcastle
university's business school
also in the uk but in brighton lawrence
haddad the executive director at the
global alliance for improved nutrition
and in nairobi peter kamalingan he's the
pan africa director at oxfam
international welcome to you all if i
could start with lawrence so lawrence
the un food price index last month
showed a rise towards record levels why
is it all down to the post-pandemic
recovery
uh thanks sami yeah the levels are
really high highest since 1975 in real
terms and i think there are three big
drivers um climate covered and conflict
on the climate side of things we've got
some pretty severe droughts and some key
food producing areas uh argentina
malaysia indonesia
ukraine russia and this is really
driving prices up because supply has
been interrupted on the covet front
we know that moving food around in food
systems from
the farm to the fork is much more
complicated under covert restrictions
and lockdowns and when you can't move
food around you can't really equalize
supply and demand and conflict is you
know conflict is
we're seeing uh the tensions around
ukraine and russia there's tensions in
ethiopia and northern nigeria and
northern mozambique northern kenya these
kind of tensions make it difficult for
people to plan for food actors farmers
producers processors to plan and so
there's uncertainty in the system and
that tends to push prices up as well
so jas is it a perfect storm of some of
the factors that lawrence was talking
about there climate covered conflict i'm
trying to see if i can add another c to
that chains of supply
yes absolutely i think i completely
agree with the points that lawrence has
raised and they definitely are having an
impact on the supply chains so um
one of the reasons uh behind this
increase uh increase in food prices is
the cost of input uh in the supply
chains are increasing so
labor uh labor costs are are on the rise
energy costs fuel costs so everything is
on the rise
let's break it down in very simple terms
people why are all those input elements
going up
yeah so i think it's
one of the biggest reason is the
increase in the uh
the the price of the wholesale wholesale
gas which has increased by 250 percent
because of uh well one of the reasons is
that we are not producing enough energy
as much energy as we used to that's one
reason because of all the droughts in
the
uh in the in brazil and southern america
and also i mean we have had endless
vindles uh summer in 2021 so uh we are
not producing enough energy here and and
there's too much rain in in india and
china because of climate change and that
has hit all the farm supply so the
agriculture has been hit so that has led
to increase in prices also i mean more
you know closer to home in the uk
uh
because of the rise in the uh the
wholesale natural gas uh wholesale gas
which is a cree ingredient in the
fertilizer production the fertilizer uh
price has uh has uh increased which has
led to the increase in food prices also
that has led to an increase in the cost
of carbon dioxide which is a byproduct
of fertilizer production and and we know
you know we've been dealing it with it
for the past year that you know the the
sea of fertilizer which is the major
supplier of co2 in the in the uk uh it
keeps closing down the government agrees
a short term deal pays them pays them a
lot of money for three three months and
then you know after those three months
and we are hit with that again so again
these are the combination of factors
that are raising uh increasing price of
the inputs and one thing is that also
because of you know as we are uh trying
to recover the economy from curvit all
the all the pent up demand uh is is on
the rise so people are kind of ordering
more and more you know businesses are
ordering more and more and we are seeing
the classic
effect in action where as you order more
the prices increase and you know we are
unable to meet that demand so it's just
this combination of factors that's
leading to all this
so it really does sound like a perfect
storm you've prompted a a few other
questions in my mind jess but we'll come
back to that in a moment i want to bring
in peter and say what is the bottom line
of all of this especially for people
in less developed countries are they
going to be going hungry facing
starvation malnutrition
what are we looking at
yeah thanks very much i think the in
addition to i mean the colleagues who
have spoken um lawrence and they call it
who has spoken have rightly yes said
that this has been
uh
escalated by the triple c impact
conflict climate and and and copy
but i think that the the thing that we
need to underscore is that even before
all these copies and before i mean there
was already a food problem in the in a
good part of the world particularly in
africa and the low-income countries and
this is largely because of a failed food
system
with her productivity is going down
increasingly partly because of inputs
which are going high but a lot of that
is because of sustained many decades of
disinvestment on small
food producers family producers small
farmers small-scale farmers there's a
lot of this investment in productivity
in africa there have been for many years
a commitment to invest at least 10
percent of the budget
on on on agriculture and food production
that has not been
possible
it's actually much worse now because
many of the economies are increasingly
suffocating under an increasing uh
public debt crisis so there's a huge
problem the global food system the
capture by the big uh corporate sector
in the in the food system is i think
where the problem is and then we're not
investing in productivity we're not
investing why not theater so this is
i think that as i said there's a capture
there's a tendency for capture by the
big corporates uh which is also
suffocating the policy space for average
governments to invest in agriculture
there's been a lot of emphasis on light
scale land based investments and this
investment on small food producers and i
think that that's where so you're
basically saying
countries are falling victim to big
multinational corporations
absolutely at least for for for africa
where i'm speaking from yes that's
exactly the truth
interesting lawrence do you agree with
that well you know i do i do think
there's an over concentration of power
amongst big corporates in uh africa and
south asia and this is this is a this is
an issue
but i think a big part of the problem is
just governments not investing as as
peter said in in
you know we we for the first time ever
we have a science-based roadmap on how
to end hunger by 2030. we know what to
do and we even have it costed out it
will cost an extra 33 billion dollars a
year that sounds like a lot but it's
only really a doubling of what we
already spend and it's it's basically
the equivalent of the increase in net
wealth of the world's 10 richest
billionaires over the last year but
lawrence are governments failing to do
that because of mismanagement on their
part or
is the is the situation as peter seemed
to be saying because there's there's a
lack of policy spaces i think the word
the nice term coined there because of
the big multinational corporation
i don't really agree with that i mean
the malibu there the african nations
have a target of 10 they've set
themselves that that target and the last
report
by the african union on progress towards
those targets shows really um some
countries doing very well but but most
of the countries actually lagging far
behind i think you know the former head
of the un food agency always used to say
there's no union for hungry people
there's no way they can have their voice
properly heard they can't put pressure
on governments very well unless it comes
through the last resort which is writing
in the streets in the rural areas so
governments need to feel the heat a
little bit more all right i could see
peter was angling to get in with a
comeback go ahead peter
yes i do agree that obviously i'm not
here i don't want to observe you know
exonerate african government these are
leaders of several states definitely
they do have some scope they haven't
maximized the scope they have i think
the reference to that malabar
degradation yes it can be done but i
think let us realize
that the reality of
these countries is much more than we we
would just imagine because
for example these are countries where
for some of them probably 60 percent of
their national budget is not going to be
paying date
the fiscal space is much smaller it's
worse after covering so there are
certain things that they can do but
there's a lot that is outside the
control of african governments but even
then they haven't come together this is
why we are really asking them to do what
they can to be able to at least deliver
what they have committed to including
that malleable commitment but i think
that it's important to realize that some
of the large corporates have a turnover
that is you know significantly higher
than the turnover of some of these
governments so they do have
undue influence of policy decision
making including other national
parliaments national legislative
processes they are much more powerful
than we can imagine so there has to be
solidarity there has to be an
understanding that if we don't
take collective work together as
lubricator systems whether through the
u.n structure the airfare commitments if
we don't do
things for example to elicit financial
flows where these countries are losing
money because of weaknesses in global
tax regulatory systems if we don't do
all those things to expand the physical
space it's going to be difficult for
these governments to accurately live and
invest in food production
interest i would agree with that i would
agree with that sammy and peter but i
think the we we never talk about the
quiet revolutionaries in the food system
in africa which are the smaller medium
enterprises and we need to find ways to
get more private uh credit and equity
from investors to those quiet
revolutionaries most people who are on
low incomes get their food through
smaller medium enterprises and
smallholder farmers we need to support
them
much more we did an okay job during
covert but we need to keep supporting
them with credit equity and technical
assistance
i want to go back to jess and pick you
up on a point you mentioned you were
saying there the world is simply not
producing enough energy is there an
element of perhaps mismanagement
collectively for the world in not seeing
that obviously the day was going to come
when
things would pick up after the pandemic
did we fail
to put production in the right place and
then in anticipation of that
um i think uh there was um on some level
it was that
also i think
there has been this uh continuing to
sort of the theme of the disinvestment
that we've been talking about
we have been thinking about you know
exploring other sources of energy and
not relying on you know sort of the
traditional fuel and and gas what has
happened is that um although we there's
a lot of research going on unless it's
commercially viable it's not going to
see see the funding so for example
there's a lot of talk about ccus carbon
capture utilization uh and storage
technology but it's
the cost of for setting that up and
increasing the uh the capacity of
storing carbon and and using it um it's
it's just not commercially viable yet so
i think that has been a problem uh for
for the country even though we we do we
do want to achieve net zero and
everything uh also i mean in general um
it is also a classic over uh
i wouldn't say overreaction i think
that's that's the wrong thing to say but
what's going on uh with the russia and
ukraine situation russia is the third
biggest oil producer in the world and at
the moment you know you start thinking
about hey what's going on there there
going to be an oil shortage there would
be an increase in demand
so that has been more of a recent thing
but the demand has been increasing and
that has led to an increase in price
throughout the supply chain which
eventually uh get increases the price
and you know uh pushes it back to the
consumer and i think finally i mean we
we know about the you know uh the the
lorry driver shortage the truck drivers
shortage that has been going on and uh
so that has ex that has sort of extended
on there on the shipping side so a lot
of energy uh fuel is uh transported uh
exported right and we need we need ships
for that who have the who have the
specialist equipment now what happens is
people are refusing to get on shift
because what haven't been ever given
last year and also what was happening
with people over there who were stuck at
ships way past their contract due dates
that they don't want to catch over also
they want they don't want to get bad
treatment and they were literally
surviving on one loaf of bread um a day
so they don't want to get into that
situation again and they want to get
more clarity so the shipping of fuel has
also been impacted so some of that has
been uh i mean when we talk about supply
chain risk management we say no unknowns
and um unknown uh unknown unknown so
this is like so sorry no unknown no no
no so this that has been element of this
unknown unknown that has been happening
but they were quite a bit of known
known unknowns which could have been
managed
gosh it does sound really like a perfect
storm of factors then with the world or
some countries at least not investing
already enough in food production and
then you know along comes covidon
conflict and climate change just to make
everything more complicated let's take
it back to peter and oxfam and ask the
question now lawrence mentioned a good
point support of small and medium-sized
enterprises realistically speaking who
can give that support and how important
a role can they play
in food security in this
era of mega corporations and
globalization
yeah thanks i think that there's
there's logic in that in investing in
small and medium enterprises family
farming and all that but i think it's
important that your government should do
that but i think that a lot of these
governments as i've said are
increasingly finding it difficult to do
that because of an expanding uh public
debt problem
and the other thing is also of course
that the the climate in fact are
continuing to make it much harder for
them to produce uh to to you know the
weather patterns are changing and
shifting in ways that
the partners cannot i mean the farmers
cannot cope uh there's of course a
fusion of course of the big corporates
together with the state that is making
it difficult especially the vulnerable
small farmers to actually you know
produce enough food for themselves peter
i'm wondering does all of that really
give an incentive against these poor
small farmers then because
if you're going to invest in somebody
are you going to look to the most
vulnerable small farmers who might not
be able to survive covid and conflict
and climate change and droughts or will
you look to you know put your
bet your money on huge corporations
i think that the truth is that
no matter what we put it at the moment
the market system has failed at least
the vulnerable what we know is that the
small producers are still the most
important the problem is that they are
not having enough investment in terms of
technology in terms of input in terms of
access to credit affordable credit that
is not happening in the majority of the
the countries at least in africa as far
as i can see and i think that that's
where the future that's where the hope
is and that's where we're saying that
you know the agricultural policies and
investments should be directed at the
small food producers
that granted it must be accompanied by
investments in technology in training in
agricultural extension services
and also in terms of the movement the
movement the market systems need to be
regulated in a way that does not clock
the space for the small food producers
as i have said there have been a lot of
investment on large-scale land producers
and the experts of the small farmers and
that's the reason why we are having a
problem no matter what we say probably
70 of the food in africa
is still is still a matter of small
farmers and that's where we need to
direct our investments as far as i can
see
after all i think they're the ones that
are impacted most at the moment the the
the the issue also
as i said again um
these countries uh are not poor they
have been made poor by global policies
as i said again for example africa is
losing 70
billion 60 70 billion dollars every year
to elicit financial flows so if that can
be
there can be multilateral mechanisms to
able to cap that and redirect that to to
to to food production yes it is possible
i think that they are it's also
important to understand that this uh
these impacts of food hunger issues are
not gender blind they're impacting like
women and children and i think that we
need to have policies that are clearly
directed and focus on on those the
majority of the continent where we see
the biggest food crisis is still you
know countries that have governors
problems they have issues of conflict
violence displacement that simply means
that people don't have the time they
don't have the space they don't have the
peace right to actually produce food
they have to rely on
on charity which i think is not where
any of us wants wants to be
i think that the apple can go relying on
food coming from abroad because you
don't have the time to produce it
yourself lawrence in light especially of
the pandemic is the world
moving even more towards a globally
supplied food supply rather than
you know local production
sort of covered speeding up that process
well i don't think it's inevitable i
think the the choices are there for
policy makers you know we need to
diversify i think we've probably over
over invested in global value change and
global supply chains and i think we're
now seeing how fragile the food system
is i mean covet 19 was devastating for
for humanity and in a massive stress
test for the food system and i'd say the
food system failed desperately in pretty
much every country and that's because it
was reliant on just-in-time global value
chains so i'm not saying no trade of
course not
international
value chains are critical but we need a
greater diversity of the length both
spatially and temporarily are value
chains and i think we are seeing a
return
to local production regional production
um more into trade more more trade
within africa with a new free trade zone
within africa that's going to be vital
so i think i think you know it's really
important and it's not just about
smallholder farmers it's about the small
processors the small retailers the small
marketers these are companies that
employ 5 10
15
up to 100 people and they are going to
be the future of african food systems
but we need to invest in them otherwise
the big corporates will take over and
we'll just have all the problems we have
in the uk will have the same problems in
sub-saharan africa and africa
interesting i want to bring jason on the
first point of what lawrence was talking
about there are we seeing supply chains
change jazz as a result of that failure
are we seeing a move at least to some
degree away from
you know reliance on the global supply
chain
uh yes yes so i'm just responding to
what lauren said about that and and also
partially to what peter said about uh
you know supporting uh local local
capabilities so yes i mean at the outset
yes um
there is a change being um change being
observed of kind of moving from global
supply chains to to uh more regional
local supply chains um
but there is a problem with that that
you know if you if you trade for a long
time whether it's manufacturing all
service or full production as we have
seen uh global supply chains are fragile
as we have seen in the pandemic what
happens is also that you lose capability
over time so
you lose the knowledge over time of how
to manufacture how to produce of certain
things now what happens is that if you
want to kind of reinvigorate those local
capabilities what needs to happen is
that rather than relying on global
values we have to identify regional
clusters and invest into them and
develop them to to become to develop
that those kind of national capabilities
and that partially goes into
what peter was saying about supporting
supporting local farmers and you know a
small small and medium enterprises and i
once i think that yes government does
have a role to play in that i think
industries big corporations also have a
role to play in that so what they can do
and we have seen some some successes
recently in the uk but you know there's
a lot that needs to be done what they
need to do is instead of relying on
traditional supply suppliers traditional
global bigger suppliers they need to
invest in local supply chain so try and
work with local suppliers and integrate
them into their own supply chains
however that needs work you need a
different style of contracting you then
need different payment terms you need to
understand what their issues are and
that kind of goes to social value in
addition to economic value i think sami
the kind of world we're in right now
really values and puts a premium all
right i'm sorry we're gonna have to end
it there because we are out of time
terribly sorry guys
i know we can go on talking about this
i'm sure we will be back to talk about
it later but for now we've got to end it
let's thank our guests jas calra
lawrence haddad and peter kamelingen and
thank you two for watching you can see
the show again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com for further
discussion head over to our facebook
page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle there is at aj inside story
from me sami zaydan and the entire team
here for now it's goodbye